on vient justement d'en parler le
ministre François bernardel le ministre
de la Sécurité publique a déposé un
projet de loi qui propose de changer
plusieurs dispositions en matière de
sécurité publique entre autres établir
un encadrement plus serré des
interpellations policières celles qu'on
dit aléatoire comme je le rappelais
alors pour en parler on l'accueille
François bernardel bonjour monsieur
bernardel
bonjour alors le projet de loi il
prévoit des obligations supplémentaires
de réduction de compte pour les cordes
de police notamment si le projet doit
être adopté tel quel produire chaque
année un rapport au ministre pour faire
état de toutes les interpellations
policières qui sont effectuées je sais
pas combien il y en a mais je me demande
si c'est réaliste
ce sont des informations qui sont déjà
corrigés qui sont déjà faits par
certains corps de police autant pour les
interpellations que les interceptions
est-ce qu'on souhaite c'est qu'à chaque
première ville de chaque année que les
corps de police puissent nous donner ces
informations que l'on va corriger qui
comme de mentionner qui n'ont jamais été
corrigés du côté du ministère de la
série publique donc ça va donner les
informations pour être capable de
prendre des décisions au futur je veux
un loi qui pourrait modifier dans
peut-être 10 15 20 ans il faut
comprendre qu'elle loi sur
la police a été modernisée depuis les 20
dernières années donc on va établir des
lignes directrices qui vont définir le
fait qu'un policier ne peut pas
interpeler ou intercepter un plaignant
une personne sur des motifs
discriminatoires mais en quoi le fait de
les avoir vous puisque elles existent
déjà ces données là en quoi les obtenir
ça vous aidera à prévenir le profilage
racial
quelques policiers qui qui ont fait face
à la Commission à regarderontologie qui
ont eu des plaintes de certaines
personnes alors faut pas mettre tous les
policiers dans le même bain on a besoin
que les policiers soient bien
accompagnés pour bien faire leur travail
c'est pour ça qu'on a porté un appel
aussi le jugement hier jour on croit que
les policiers ont besoin de faire des
interceptions des interpellations dans
un cadrement avec des lignes précises et
de s'assurer qu'ils ont les outils pour
bien faire leur travail bon justement
vous en fait mention monsieur bernardel
le gouvernement on appelle de la
décision du juge Gier jour qui était
rendu au mois d'octobre on ordonnait la
fin des interceptions sans motif
valables est-ce que ces changements-là
que vous proposez découle du jugement du
juge
viennent du travail qui ont été faits le
par plusieurs personnes la Commission
sur la réalité consultative sur la
réalité policières le groupe d'action
qu'on le racisme donc ce sont des
demandes que même des recommandations
que même nous envoyer à savoir il serait
intéressant qu'on a des lignes
directrices un pouvoir réglementaire
donc on est allé chercher le corrigé de
l'information à gauche et à droite avec
ses différentes commissions on a
rencontré mon collègue Christopher ski
et moi la ministre responsable de la
lutte contre différents groupes après
les fêtes donc je pense qu'on a trouvé
l'équilibre qui est intéressant du côté
du travail des policiers vous en avez
parlé un peu tantôt aussi du côté des
personnes disparues on pourra parler si
vous souhaitez donc le gouvernement va
maintenir ce qu'on appelle
tout à fait vous estimez que ça demeure
un outil
utile pour pour les policiers vous avez
mentionné justement le ministre ski on
l'a entendu
dire le pas été fini être noir n'est pas
un motif si c'est ça le motif c'est pas
acceptable on est ailleurs et à
l'entendre là moi j'ai compris que
c'était un pas été que les corps
policiers s'en donnaient à cœur joie
c'est ça que ça que ça traduisait ça
déclarationne je le dis très
respectueux policiers font tout un
travail tout un travail et de leur dire
qu'il y a il n'y a pas de racisme
systémique dans les corps de police et
ce qui peut y avoir eu des cas de
profilage dans les derniers mois
dernières années dans certains policiers
assurément il y en a eu il y a des
teintes face à la commission mais on
veut être capable de bien encadrer
d'avoir une formation en continu c'est
qu'il va permettre de de mieux former
ces policiers qui sont arrivés comme
policier voilà 15 ans 20 ans on sait que
le travail de la police a bien changé
dans les 20 dernières années on a qu'à
penser à la santé mentale 80% des appels
du 9 forum à Montréal c'est les appels
de santé mentale alors les 50% des
appels partout sur le territoire
québécois sont les appels qui sont qui
concerne la santé mentale donc le
travail
on est même évolué énormément changé je
pense que c'est important aujourd'hui de
bien les encadrer pour leur dire que
leur travail immense et important pour
s'assurer trouver l'équilibre entre la
prévention et la répression
et bien on va suivre la progression de
ce projet de loi François bernardel
merci beaucoup pour cette entrevue
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI